you
Ron Johnson good to see you
you're awkward yeah this is how I open
most conversations with with people I
know so how's it going good good so why
don't we why don't we level set a little
bit um so you have had quite a quite an
epic career in retail among other things
sort of the the kind of the the driver
and and and really kind of the growth
engine behind the Apple store you went
off to to run JCPenney we'd love to just
get into the state of retail in general
based on that and now you are a start-up
founder with enjoy and so so pretty
awesome so just to kind of kick kick
things off can you kind of set up the
state of the retail industry broadly
particularly with a lens toward the
brick-and-mortar part of the retail
world here's the way I look at it stores
have been around a long time so the
Apple store on Regent Street in London
has had the same landlord for over a
thousand years so the point is people
have been trying to make money in
physical retail for thousands plus years
ecommerce is 20 years old it's like a
baby it's really early there's one
dominant player Amazon right but the
share of it's really small total global
e-commerce is 5% of sales in the u.s. at
7 it's growing faster but its rate of
growth in 20 years it might be 18
percent unless something changes so
stores are the kind of stalwart it's
kind of a habit whether it's age of
customers ecommerce is the new disruptor
or new entrant the theory we have
without jumping into it is that
ecommerce today is fundamentally solved
the problem of convenience transactional
convenience Amazon is like Walmart was
in the eighties broad assortment fair
price fast if you look at the world of
stores there are many stars that compete
on something called personal service to
date there are very few places when you
start online
you have a service model there
exceptions like Trent Club maybe Warby
Parker and what they're doing bringing
five frames but the vast majority of
e-commerce is fundamental optimism low
price but that's not the history retail
so I believe for retail online to grow
people have to invest in different kind
of pain points and solve those for
customers you know some I read as
e-commerce is coming but it's not gonna
take over overnight you know it's going
to increasingly scale but stores gonna
be around for a long time so did that
drive the premise of enjoy like like
sort of finding the missing gap of
e-commerce and it's fun what drove the
premise of enjoy was one having been at
Apple you know Apple is legendary
probably more than anything for ease of
use going back to the Mac to the phone
yet the busiest store in the world is
the Apple Store and all the customers
are in the back they are in the front
they're in a line when we launch and
they buy a lot for so if an apple
customer that kind of easy views needs
help what about the rest
secondly the world's going to connect to
devices any one device on its own is not
that hard to use once you learn how to
do it but to get your smart phone to
talk to your nest thermostat to talk to
your doorbell to do that's complexity in
this smart home connected home someone's
going to have to solve or handle the
complexity in so in a world where
delivery is becoming ubiquitous where
people want to work mobile II think of
people driving for uber kids drive for
uber because they want convene a work
when they want where they want they want
freedom in a world of delivery where
people want to work Mobley my sense is
that what if you could move the location
from the physical place where you buy
the product to the physical place where
you use the product and could that not
unlock a paradigm of service because
when you're in the home you can do so
much right unlock a smartphone at home I
can take out your iPad Mac and make sure
they're all saying
I can go to your car and set up your
Bluetooth device I can make sure it
works with your signage you got the
latest software updated I couldn't do
that in the store right
but because physical stores require high
margin to support the infrastructure you
can deliver a person to someone's home
on time a lot cheaper you deliver a
store so as long as you have stores
there will be money that supports a
model like we have if that makes sense
and early on you know it's you know you
have to grow these businesses but it's
about speed and about service and a
portion of the customers and a portion
of the products will I believe require
that not at all but a significant
proportion so enjoy sort of a Genius Bar
inside your living room yeah well the
Genius Bar is really about technical
help sir enjoys at the front end of a
purchase the consumer electronics
industry in the u.s. is 225 billion
dollars people buy 225 billion of new
stuff every year every one of those
people are doing it themselves they're
on their own mm-hmm you know we want to
take part of that turn 225 billion and
do it together you know help people
through that this is a community thing
you know it's community it's community
thing it's a high-touch experience in a
high-tech world what and and we can get
into some of the specifics about kind of
the enjoy strategy in a few minutes but
maybe just does a quick kraler to that
do you see clearly right now the
branding the message is about complex or
semi complex technologies and
electronics and smart home and drones
yep but equally you know we were just
talking about other high-touch kinds of
products and services there's there
might be fashion there might be jewelry
that might be do you see getting into
those categories yep oh but okay you
know I look at it Amazon built its model
from 94 to about 97 on books they took
books figured out how to deliver books
fast and cheap with broad assortments
we've picked consumer electronics to
learn how to deliver a person in a
product fast with great help once we
learn how to do that it opens up all
kinds of other industries where someone
needs help whether it's home health care
high-end fashion
like we're already in discussions with
Selfridges confidentially I guess not
confident about how you enjoy Selfridges
in a city like London you know so
there's a lot of interesting plays down
the road but for us to deliver a person
it's got to be a purchase that matters
pretty good retail pretty good margin
pretty good economics you know and most
products have those you know I don't
think about growing and building an
organization like this you're hiring
policies your customer service policies
and how does that different from your
previous experiences at both Apple and
JCPenney yeah this is like an
application
I mean Apple the premise of the store
was the people that work there whether
it's at the Genius Bar you meet great
people so we had to learn how to hire
trained build a culture of service enjoy
is that on steroids because our product
is a person what we have is a person and
an experience we create so we've got to
do an even better job of selecting
people training people delivering you
know incredible every time and so it's
really hard so how do you do that well
you it's it's actually quite simple you
know having been in the industry a long
time 20 million people now are working
in the mobile economy all right you've
got to start by creating the best job
for a mobile economy so we don't have
contractors we have employees and
they've got salaries and the benefits in
stock but just like when you work for
uber they have no boss set in their
schedule so if you're a full-time
employee you work 40 hours a week
maintain 40 hours of availability we pay
you so if you're a student you can go to
class you can go do this you can do that
you can be in a rock concert you work
when you want which is why you want to
work with uber but you've got the
hallmarks of a great job which is a
guaranteed salary amount of team so you
start by creating a job that will
attract good people then you've got to
have a profile of who do you pick and
you pick people in our case who love
technology and love people very simple
those are the track if they love
technology they'll learn on their own
they're inquisitive and if they love
people you know aren't awkward they'll
do
but they'll naturally come on I would be
an okay enjoy employer okay but they'll
deliver like Ethernet I'm pretty okay
but for us the the beauty for us on the
server side is that bars really looks
it's never been done before so if
someone shows up like in your time in
they show up five minutes earlier they
hand-deliver product they're really nice
they get you up and running you know
it's not just set up it's learning how
to use it on board it's solving your
problems and they're really friendly and
it was free what's not to like so did
you actually then methodically go
through all the list of product
categories yeah okay
and then electronics I mean it wasn't
just because you're the Apple guy it was
because I thought it was the best
category because of the complexity right
and this future I've connected home the
smart home will happen but it's not
happening yet you talked to Tony Fadell
talk to him next week his biggest
inhibitors people would love to control
but they don't know how to do that and
they don't want to hire some installer
to come out and spend a hundred bucks to
get them to do their thing so so you
know we were also talking about how
product companies and brands can go
direct to customers now they could
either do that via website or they could
they could you know do their own
delivery model but essentially you can
become a distribution channel well
that's that's what wasn't discussed yet
right sure and maybe it was in your
write-up but our secret sauce is we're
helping a manufacturer bypass the store
that adds zero value so what enjoy is
doing we're in the process right now
we're in about eight companies when you
go to buy so knows next time sixty-one
percent of the people as part of their
research go to the manufacturer website
to learn about the product then they
also watch youtube videos do ratings
reviews and get recommendations but what
they do have to run the manufacturer
site is they go find a store they don't
really buy direct from manufacturers
today well on the Sonos website on the
home page and you're looking at the Play
five it'll say you can have this hand
delivered and set up in your home by six
o'clock tonight
because our pas in our time availabe
feeds right into their website that lets
you just click and buy because of the
speed convenience in the help and it's
free so most likes it because once
someone goes to Best Buy they're
standing in front of Sonos in beats
music and blah blah blah blah blah blah
so you never want to let a customer
leave without buying alright so in that
case they pay us a fee to go do this
experience for them but it allows them
to go direct and bypass the store so we
negotiate a separate price with Sonos
when we do a delivery but we look at
we're getting paid to acquire customer
now once we're through the door what
else can you enjoy so when we set up
your Sonos we start by saying what's
let's check the speedy or wireless
network right yeah you've got some Wi-Fi
issues yeah I do yeah yeah and you know
this download speed is you know you can
get faster with AT&T broadband than what
you're using I will use the 18 G
broadband yeah but the point is you
unlock a lot of potential when you get
in so I was wrong so it's not Genius Bar
in your living room I mean it is but
it's actually Genius Bar for all of
these brands for all these brands right
we're gonna be what we're trying to do
is own the cart of the premium brands
premium brands never get discounted you
know it rarely is Apple on sale where
arolea senescence it rarely is a DJI
drone on sale you can sometimes use your
red card and save 5% but these are not
heavily so we can't pick like a
specialist or the products that are the
key core products in the industry so
we're trying to be more of an art in
every industry in retail you're there's
low price guys and there are
differentiators we're trying to be the
differentiator so if we get really lucky
long term you see Prime you'll think of
speed you see enjoy you'll think of help
or a person but that's the whole vision
there is it we're gonna be the one who
owns delivering great people you trust
when you start online and want a person
so that from an economic standpoint
because there's this big question
certainly in the valley of like do these
delivery companies make money you know
if if you're paying so much for the
actual person and then the gas in the
car and
so your economics are coming from the
the buyer or and or the brand or just
about ours we always deliver free okay
so when they buy from our site we work
off the same economics the retail store
does we get the premium retail economics
because of what we're doing think 30
points so in a 500 dollar item sound
speaker we're getting a hundred 50 bucks
so you're getting the product for
wholesale selling it at the recommended
retail price and you're getting the
margin so think it's honest 150 dollars
if we sell it if they sell it we
negotiate a price that's lower but we
get a customer and we just have to
deliver a person so to deliver a person
you've got a Drivetime and you've got an
experienced time now we say we'll spend
an hour we spend the right amount of
time it takes us about 20 minutes to set
up a sono speaker and then you spend
time you know downloading different spot
at different music apps and they enjoy
that and then when you're done you go
but you know so what does it cost to
hire someone well the average Weber
driver makes 20 bucks an hour we should
pay more than that
but if we're getting a hundred 150
dollars per visit you start to see the
mass so the question is how many visits
per day can an expert do and there's a
break-even but you need scale to do that
so you have to assemble the partners you
got to get the big partners like an AT&T
you know but ultimately that's kind of
the business model but if in joy gets to
scale yeah the incumbent retailers
probably won't sit still they can't
compete and so there's no way Best Buy
is dimmed with enjoy Best Buy owns all
the physical stores so a great physical
retailer Best Buy will earn 3% after all
their expenses right because they've got
to have checkout they got to maintain
inventory they got a rent pay rent they
got to depreciate they got to hire
people and you're busy you're not busy
all right they have lost Prevention's
security they had a lot of costs they
can't afford to do it so Best Buy is
this thing called the Geek Squad but
that's a for-profit charge to visit
thing if you want to do songs the best
bites $99 come to the house so they
couldn't have those guys do it for free
cuz they got to pay them but there's no
margin to work with because they spend
it all on the store
so a physical store made their bet on
the physical experience
we've made our bet on the personal
experience on the person so our only
cost is to deliver a person makes sense
the physical of the employee cost in an
Apple store is 11 percent of sales an
apple store
that's all our expenses people so you
can see we work off the same margin
there's quite a bit of when you really
get into it so when when you think about
the retailers that are maybe most
impacted by this do you do you have a
sense of you know we were talking about
is it the people that are urban or the
people that are in more DNC locations or
is it by product who who can t varies by
product but here's I'd say it's early on
and we're very early on there's two
people that use enjoys people that want
convenience and they want help
so our speed is what gets a millennial
guy to want something because we deliver
in four hours two hours for an Apple TV
that's pretty fast right so people want
the speed but it turns out even the
young guys take the help you know it was
in our generation our generation that
years it was kind of cool to figure out
how to set up like a Mac today like an
analog clock nobody wants it but today
people it's all different remember in an
affluent society service goes up in
affluence as a service goes up that's
just to rule the world so this idea that
just because the Internet's growing that
in a future world nobody cares about
service right it's kind of crazy so if
you really think about the world we're
in the e-commerce is really great at
convenience but what else does it do I
don't see that right so in an affluent
society where you need how you want
service and people want to do I think
there's a so one clarifying questions
are in your business you're gonna have
these you're gonna manage inventory and
your yeah okay but we get it consigned
right okay so we get the paid for by our
manufacture
and you know like for instance in the
berry we need to inventory to cover the
whole Bay Area best fight needs it for
42 stores they got to make the bet where
the inventory goes before the customer
comes I take a pile the inventory just
have to read how to deliver it
efficiently
right so we have very little inventory
serving an entire market you know
compared to a physical store which needs
to anticipate through a variety
algorithms where the customer is going
to buy and that's very inefficient
that's why they run on eight weeks of
military where we can run on days do you
become constrained to larger urban areas
no that's not sure that's a fallacy too
because if you think about it if I were
in the Twin Cities where I grew up I
could drive anywhere in Minneapolis st.
Paul area is serving two million people
in 35 minutes a car the way the freeways
work you know maybe 40 but an average
drive to a will be 25 minutes in
Manhattan it sometimes takes 15 minutes
to get through the doorman to get up to
like a high-rise so when you start to go
there's trade-offs and the logistics
have to vary by market but you can
deliver people in all the major metro
areas
80% of apples revenue comes in the top
25 US cities so all of those are good
markets for enjoy right and you just
have you know a different model how then
important because when you think about
your own advantages and the things that
you guys are going to invest really
really deeply and clearly service people
and the people's eyes n clear on that
and and will be the only place to do
this with great products right because
the manufacturer is going to pick their
pick one enjoy right so that's you don't
want to train another you know happy
right you know they're gonna want to
have a partner for the loss that we
didn't have any up yeah yeah so so so
people for the service yeah and and all
the training that goes into that the
partnerships and the brand that gets you
those partnerships how about the
technology stack though do you think you
get better at logistics than other
people do you get better at dated sort
of from a you know heat mapping of
customers is that does that become an
advantage where you're years ahead of
all the problems yeah we have huge
teams so we know in the home speeds and
networks what they own who they are our
data goes immediately to a partner
Porter will son Oh sees every customer
right who they were what they owned what
their experience was so there's this
real-time feedback yeah we depressed the
other interesting thing is we've
eliminated the idea of return so returns
and consumer electronics run ten percent
we have had twenty five returns in eight
months people return things when they
can't figure out how to get it up when
they don't use it well we get we don't
leave till they're enjoying that product
right so our return rate is about one
percent so that means and we're in a
five hundred dollar car publish
manufacturer we're saving them fifty
dollars at a minimum by just solving
returns hmm
there's no call center cost every call
center costs about five dollars when you
amortize it all that goes away you know
so for what they pay us they start to
reap these disruptive benefits from the
work we do of eliminating returns
eliminating support costs yeah you know
immediate feedback that has value you
know so that's why all these
manufacturers are fighting to get
enjoying their car how disruptive do you
think are the maybe the players that
aren't focused on the service side of
this space but pure just delivery like
you know get getting things in twenty
minutes do you think that ends up being
a problem for retailers or is that I
think it's right yeah because because
the reason we have stores is because yet
now right I mean I think it is that's
where I think you know it's deceiving
Walmart and Target are really going hard
to go online right but why would I go by
target online when I Drive by the damn
store every day you know they already
invested in convenience with the number
of stores they have in these big stores
you know so if there's less likelihood I
might go to Amazon find something
different but if targets assortments
fundamentally the same as the store the
brain doesn't matter as much an online
world I can just go anywhere I don't get
it I just think it's right that's why
target's been invested billion dollars
in and I'm a little target guy it's less
than two percent of their revenue well
obviously if people are buying higher
percent from others at our customer kind
of goes now targets that store thing
yeah if I'm gonna buy convenience I'll
go to Amazon
primum you know they already made that
call so I think I think someone had it
right these big large real-estate stores
that are built on convenience it's
pretty hard to succeed in this future
world does the enjoy model work globally
are there cultural differences or things
that make it harder or easier in other
parts of the planet uh uh you know I
don't know it'll work better in like
London it's much more a delivery service
culture and for a variety reasons very
easy to get around there are other
cities it's hard to tell but I mean
where deliveries taking office we almost
China I mean that's where it's happening
but yeah we'll say the advantages every
product we offer is a global problem so
all of our partners can't wait for us
once we prove it go you know we've got
the partners lined up you get the
technology stack we've got the business
model we just have to hire people and
train people of the existing incumbent
retailers do you think anybody is is
solving this problem well and and
addressing the dilemma investing in
digital and actually migrating the
customer demand to that or is it all is
everybody seeing it as cannibalizing and
you know I think the the narrower
assortment the better opportunity you
have to do this okay and that's where
you see some yeah so why is that well
because you have a less frequent
customer coming to your store you know
and and then the better so there's no
peer play there's no such thing as a
pure play online store those don't work
you know it's another fascinating thing
if you build a physical store anywhere
in the world after about five years
everyone has discovered tried it within
the trade area and it's called amateur
store and that's when you start growing
to 3% but you fundamentally had your
experience it's also the same online
it's like I've invested in a retailer
called Nasty Gal anybody know Nasty Gal
Sofi amaura they've been around nine
years now well everyone who might be
their customers heard of NASCO they've
tried it in their market even though
it's a global online marketplace at some
point it's no different than the trader
of a store people have tried it it's
mature
now to compete you got to find a new way
to acquire customers well that's why
these company is not saying well let's
go backwards to physical you know and
start to have this omni-channel thing
which will happen is important because
sometimes you want to shop in the store
sometimes online for all these reasons
but you're gonna find a peer play online
thing except for like Amazon which is so
big in scale probably doesn't work peer
play store doesn't work you know you got
to find a way to offer more but it's
gonna be very hard for a large physical
footprint store to build an online
business so what what could disrupt
Amazon then because in a world where
convenience and speed moves from wanting
things in a day or two to an hour or two
certainly the service model that you're
building out could be disruptive but are
there any other approaches whether it's
jet or or more of the pure online
commerce yeah I think what I've always
wondered is like what the hell does
Apple sell through Amazon
what should disrupt Amazon is why should
a manufacturer go through Amazon if you
want to buy a Mac you know we're not
Amazon you buy from Apple calm you know
now you're to a point but what does
Amazon really do why would the
manufacturers not bypass that's what I
wonder you know in a future world why
isn't it and there's a way that it's so
easy to search and buy direct from the
manufacturer why would they want to
control that part of the value chain
okay throw out a hypothesis because
because there's a consumer you don't
always sort of know all the brands or
and you want to be able have a single
destination to search and find all this
in here so what's your response to that
well but people when they go to Amazon
they know what they're gonna buy I don't
when someone walked in the Apple Store
the day they bought 91% of the p90 1%
but the exact they knew the size the
model even her memory the color they'd
done their homework it was a transaction
that might be true for the higher and
yeah I'm margin price you were
describing but somebody go to Amazon and
say I want a USB charger and I'll see
the 15 that are on there I don't care
about brand I just want to kind of find
the one that looks I don't want to go to
like crestcom to get my toothpaste you
know
that's probably true okay so maybe
Amazon you know is that is just a nice
sort of low in toothpaste provider in
the future yeah we've pressed if crest
said Aaron should brush his teeth you
know once he sees a new toothpaste once
a month yep I'm a set of subscription
model a little bit of Al you you know
you love crest you're my guy right for
the next two years I'm delivering you
your toothpaste I don't have like 17
different boxes coming every single week
it's like I got my beef jerky box and
then I've got my crest box and yeah okay
cool
floss is gonna be a different company
that's true right you're gonna get
there's some so then you get back to the
delivery right yeah okay sounds like a
lot of stuff is changing in the world
clearly e-commerce has many many years
to to kind of continue to transform I
think that's who I remember it's a very
very early early cool well thank you
very much Ron